how's it goin resume welcome back to
some more Walking Dead for 100 days we
just finished I don't remember her name
that's how fast it went I am very
curious about Vince but I think I think
which one should be [ __ ] it Vince let's
do it
I like a picture that girl is like yeah
paani [ __ ] whoa would you I already told
you wasn't me man man come on I told you
like like 20 times
no I don't even I didn't know your buck
whoa
uh Vince what the [ __ ] it kind of sucks
you know once you start to know the
character that it finishes you know uh
oh we know this we've been here in
episode 1 that's cool [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh I don't like where this is going oh
this reminds me of Lee I guess okay let
me guess someone cheated on his
girlfriend and you shot the guy and then
he'd get went to prison come on man
English it is crap anymore
two hours think it'll clear up soon well
uh traffic man supposed to have been at
the pen an hour ago so I guess this is
written for this Oh relax it's not your
fault traffic still backed up for miles
never thought I'd want to get to prison
ha ha hey knock it off the hell man what
you know cut it out
Jesus you guys you gonna make me yeah
hey Vince Justin's gonna make me just a
lot for this [ __ ] fill your brain kind
of making him hot now yeah Danny
settle down [ __ ] settle down
[ __ ] that's you started it oh yeah
yeah how about you open a [ __ ] window
it's a prison bus [ __ ] the window hey
Justin [ __ ] that guy in the beat-up
truck right I'll bet he lives in that
truck now you probably got his whole
house life savings [ __ ] I bet you stole
his dog you steal his dog man I wasn't
stealing from guys like that anyway
better than stealing his virginity
hey how many times I got to tell here we
go seriously I was falsely accused uh
how old was she 15 damn it a day like
that you telling me there wasn't a star
witness waiting around in your white van
I don't think though we're all in the
same boat here what's the point of
arguing the point is I'm not like that
boy is gonna be here no you work guys
I'm afraid to say it yeah 20 years about
me missing my girlfriend right now I
don't guess she's pretty pissed at you
worse ha ha ha what did you want to talk
to Mel haven't heard her voice in months
really messing with me I don't think
she's your girlfriend anymore just let
it go man I want to but you know call
her army oh there man
you should call her up when we get there
got to face that [ __ ] no you're right
man first call I get Danny I know you
don't realize this because you're you
but you probably ruined that poor girl
ha ha ha he's a [ __ ] ha ha big talk from
white collar back there how many lives
you wrecked kid who cares hotter than
hell up in here I'm kidding dehydrate
like that one of those black guys looks
like Chris Rock here I'm just saying
John I thought you took the stand cried
your eyes I'm telling you again you lose
your [ __ ] and tell them you didn't know
what you were doing we're all such a
lied turns out I'm good at that you lied
on the stand see that's the kind of [ __ ]
I could never do religious no man watch
a lot of cop shows no weapon it just
ain't right
Oh give me a break you should have been
a man about it I can't believe I'm
getting my moralistic [ __ ] kicked in by
a couple of criminal what what is going
on yeah us in this I don't regret any of
it I carried my victims for years they
knew what they were getting into and now
here I am and there they are and Wall
Street [ __ ] pulling the same scores
are smiling on TV
[ __ ] that how'd it all work anyway it
was like a pyramid scheme kinda [ __ ] it
was a really good pyramid scheme good
[ __ ] is still [ __ ] son honey
elegant [ __ ] elegant Chadron I live with
yourself
easy I didn't think about it how much
did you make off with anyway yeah enough
so like a couple hundred K a little over
a hundred
million goddamn once oh when we get out
of here you me and Vince we gotta go
into business know what I'm saying
you know I don't actually know a thing
about you Vince but sure he's a priest
yeah father Vincent
they touched a kid to kids you judgments
that kids Vince
I'm innocent give me a [ __ ] break man
John I can talk
yeah but Vince is full of [ __ ] I know he
did something that's just weak [ __ ] you
so what was it man must have been
something real stupid huh
forget it come on man what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do about you [ __ ] Andy Chris
Rock come down [ __ ] you [ __ ]
whoa don't kill Chris Rock hey no hey
let him go man
David Crabtree I don't mind come back
there's not a killing [ __ ] let the
guard handle it guys [ __ ] that we gotta
get in there you do not want to get in
the middle of that [ __ ] Danny I'm
helping it didn't have any balls I'm not
doing any more time to save some stupid
ass helping Danny what's that
speak up boy get you ain't too short
oh we gotta move come on no the tank I'm
warning you were lousy I gotta go get in
there something down break that [ __ ]
along man come on Oh kind of like where
this is going dammit get a feel that for
knocking out last warning document
Kouga what the [ __ ] Jesus
what did what happened god damn it boy
yippee fat guy still alive get those
cuffs off him man
that the cop is [ __ ] stupid
what the hell was that he he made a move
on me I don't know
he made a move or you don't know yeah
it's one he's still doing brain he's uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] you gotta call someone man
it's gonna call it I'm calling this in
don't don't call it any it just just
wait okay just give me a damn minutes
back my cell bill I still be alive
call a damn ambulance man I just need a
minute I need a minute to think you
ain't got a minute shut up you hear me
just shut your mouth hey hey okay okay
calm down everybody calm down get easy
and everybody needs to calm the [ __ ]
down
situations bad enough as it is he's
right let's all just take it down a
notch okay yeah oh oh oh no no no no
they want to pull that trigger again son
oh yeah that's badass that's badass
that's not some ass oh oh they're having
a party that's awesome
did you see that
I saw
yeah
hey you gotta get us the hell out we're
not going anywhere
[ __ ] God get this bus moving hey drive
sick oh man I and right here we're safe
inside the bus Oh Chris Jesus oh oh oh
oh my god hey oh my god you need to call
someone stop dancing we need them did he
just pay a lot of Jesus
uh oh back up back up [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh we can movie there okay you sure
about that
oh [ __ ] you gonna help out here Vince
come on we gotta choose whether they
find a weapon what kind of weapon you
think you're gonna find back your
[ __ ] ha ha ha where's the guards fun
yeah yeah the gun good thinking Justin
where is it
I think you fell off it's underneath oh
[ __ ] me
did it it it it it it it it it ooh you
got a gun I'm doing it
shooter that's all this do it just I am
and that's how it's done
sorry Chris Oh watch it man
typical beeps sorry typical man I can't
believe this [ __ ] can you believe this
[ __ ] man I don't believe [ __ ] we gotta
find some way to get out of here no um
okay I have a plan and it's called shoot
the window with not much you say won't
budge how about I just [ __ ] shoot
this thing
poison where are the damn keys man
they weren't on him how do you know well
[ __ ] if the keys aren't on him then
where the hell are they he must have
left them up front
he became exami - we finally caught a
break Danny hey buddy
oh [ __ ] god damn it Danny
you always put your [ __ ] fun of you
man you got to get out of here before
any more of them show up well that went
to [ __ ] fast that's not gonna hold it
fire the [ __ ] gun at them
I'd rather fire at the chain keep
shooting man whoa whoa watch it it could
work
how do you know okay
you're smart Wow mama ain't gonna work
either I think you just pissed them off
yeah
what do i do then none enough oh [ __ ]
hmm we'll never get past those bars
while I'm out of my desk hell are we
gonna get out and gotta be away can't we
just shoot off the chains no wait
wouldn't cut your word what about the
cup if we're sure one of those are uh
are you [ __ ] insane
what do you think is gonna happen if you
fire a shotgun that close to someone's
well what do you thinks gonna happen if
we don't get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ]
give me the gun we gotta do this
Oh
Oh Oh I gotta choose I'm not going with
Bieber water beats you're going I'm
sorry man [ __ ] you Owen hurry
Justin's just gonna slow you dead you're
welcome
do it again
ah uh I don't want to do it again
kidding ah come on let's go uh okay
sorry man
was that another one was that another
one that was another one that was
another one that one was awesome I
didn't expect it to all to be in the bus
that's kind of cool
ah goddamnit they're so short anyway
hope you enjoyed watching leave a like
if you did hit subscribe to become a bro
today and I've seen the next one stay
awesome breath
you